справді якщо подивитися
хто лобіює які проекти хто стоїть за
якими питаннями хто куди їздив до речі я
раджу всім хто ще не підписаний
підписатися на телеграм-канал Ніни
южаніної тому що нещодавно вона отримала
фактаж паперів надзвичайно цікавий куди
як їздили зокрема українські
чиновники з різних фінансових відомств
причому їздили у відпустки в'їздили на
конференції Тільки чомусь там гуляли дні
народження і зараз буде цілий великий я
би так сказала навіть серіал з
інформацією що куди дає як відбувалося в
той час коли порядна частина населення
або воює або волонтерець або все тіло
допомагає зміцнювати обороноздатність
нашої армії ну і ще один важливий момент
я дуже боюся що ці всі речі з оцими
всіма зашкварами вони зокрема виникають
з двох причин перша причина їх обрали
люди і зараз критично Важливо щоб їхні
виборці
усвідомили що оці всі зашквари оці всі
беспредели ці всі кримінальні потенційні
справи які чомусь ніколи не доводяться
до пуття це є наслідок їхнього
голосування наслідок їхнього вибору це
не тому що людина розбестилася там за
чотири роки а тому що людина такою була
і таку її вибрали ну в більшості
випадків і тому якщо люди хочуть мати
когось інакшого треба думати над своїм
вибором дуже серйозно а не по приколу
ржачно там тикати якусь цю галочку Ну і
другий момент що
тому всьому
складається така ситуація що ми не
можемо вплинути на остаточне притягнення
тих чи інших осіб до відповідальності
Тому ми маємо дуже пильнувати щоби якщо
когось нового призначають щоб це дійсно
була людина порядна з чистою біографією
Якщо так не є піднімати скандал завчасно
Ну як з армою про на жаль це не подіяло
лише один момент що діє насправді це
широкий громадський розголос і зокрема
по справі червінського по справі прямого
який зараз намагається рейдернути по
суті як сказав адвокат прямого пан Євген
що от розголос і гласність це те що може
привертати увагу широких сверх
суспільства і завдяки цьому Ми можемо
домагатися якоїсь справедливості зокрема
і усунення від влади зашкварених особин